first of all
we'd to speak about the timing we
said
8 45 so here we're starting at 8 55
so somebody might feel hey we lost
10 minutes you know
but honestly if it were up to me this
class would be
15 or 20 minutes long that's it
why well the reason for that
the longer i talk the more
you're going to forget what i said at
the very beginning
so this is why i prefer short classes i
don't prefer
long classes i don't prefer
hour long and i don't prefer unless it's
they come to seek a specific science in
islam
they are conditioned for these kinds of
things but for the general masses
a short amount of time is good and this
is something that we find from the
prophet sallallahu alaihis
[Silence]
being very short and his recitation
being very
long meaning on the day of jummah is an
indication of his knowledge that means
that this is a person who
is very knowledgeable right
continuing with our subject of we have
one more thing to speak about with
regards to
consoling those who have lost someone
those who are bereaved
[Silence]
he said here one thing that is of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
is that he would
command that whenever somebody a family
a tribe a family lost someone
to death that he would have other people
make food and dinner for them and
provide them with food
right as long as needed not just one
time
maybe for a few days right why because
they're mourning
[Silence]
one of the things that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would encourage is that when somebody a
family is bereaved
that they not be you know people are
coming to give their condolences
so the family may feel compelled to cook
for them
and this is wrong what really it should
be
is that we should cook for the family
that's been bereaved right
and this is what the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam said to do
that if a family is bereaved he would
command
other people to cook for them because
they are
in a state of grieving they're not in a
state
where they need to have a bunch of
guests come and they need to worry about
cooking and all that
on top of their bereavement this is
incorrect
and alhamdulillah in some cultures
we have a little bit of that still but
alhamdulillah people are starting to
catch on to the sun of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that when somebody dies in a family
other people make food for them and that
is for as long as is necessary
one day two days three days until they
you know get back on their feet
insha'allah alawa kanam and hadith
[Silence]
and
another thing which the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam prohibited
is wailing upon death
wailing have you ever heard of a banshee
anybody here ever heard of a banshee
a banshee is
a mythical creature
from irish heritage okay
and what this banshee is is that when
somebody dies
or when somebody would die they would
hear
the screams and the whales of this
banshee
creature this is what it was right
the point here is that this is an
embodiment
of the grief that strikes a person when
someone dies
so a night is when we
as soon as somebody dies it is announced
to the entire village
it is announced to the entire world so
and so has just passed
away and then a eulogy is given we know
what a eulogy
is a eulogy is when we sit and we you
know
non-muslims do in their
in their ceremonies
they will stand and give a speech about
the person who died
you know he did this and he did that and
he was a great grandfather and he
you know put the kid on his leg and one
time he did this
and one time he did that and you know
all these things right
this is all something which is
prohibited in islam
now this is something which is
and enough is said when we see
that the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was not given this
treatment that's enough correct
[Silence]
so this is a yardstick that we need to
use in our lives
okay and that is look at the treatments
of the prophet salallahu
okay when he passed away
did he receive a eulogy did the
companions
go up on the member and mention all of
his good deeds
and all of his praises and give poems
about him
no this didn't happen so if it didn't
happen for the prophet sallallahu alaihi
why should it happen for me
correct it's kind of birthdays
people ask you should we celebrate
birthdays
did the prophet salallahu celebrate his
birthday
no then why should why should i
celebrate mine
is mine more relevant than his the most
the most important influential
and most righteous man's who ever
placed the foot on this earth his
birthday was not celebrated
i should feel ashamed that mine is you
understand what i mean
this is how we should look at things we
should never look at things
as is it halal is it haram there's
nothing saying it's haram
no because culture was different at that
time we have
general things which prohibit and
allow in the sciences of islam
that's not what we're looking for if you
want to tell me now
give me an evidence that smoking is
haram
well they didn't smoke at that time you
understand
but we have general principles that all
indicate a yes or no answer
the same thing they didn't celebrate
birthdays at that time but we have
general principles that will indicate a
yes or no
answer and those principles are known to
who
the scholars of islam we need to listen
to them
we need to listen to our scholars
and when i say scholars i'm not talking
about
people that talk a lot or wear big fancy
hats
or have fancy clothes and they have the
pen
and the glasses and they walk and when
you speak to them it's you're
speaking to a king that's not who i'm
taught those are not scholars
that's not who i'm speaking about
a scholar is somebody who has knowledge
of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sunnah and it has
touched
his heart
the great imam he said knowledge
is a light that resonates from the heart
that's what knowledge is mashy
we we get fooled easy right
we get fooled easy he has a diploma he
has a nice
jubba he has a big hat that goes out all
the all directions
right it's red it's white it's all these
different colors
when he walks he walks like
[Silence]
foreign
is
[Silence]
foreign
the issue of respect for scholars
and unfortunately it's hard to drive
this point home anymore
respect for scholars why
because we can't even tell who's a
scholar anymore and who isn't
that's the problem right
the problem is is that scholars
and fools are
all they they seem to look the same to
us we can't tell which one is which
and we're easily fooled by the
bedazzlement
of people you know if someone comes
walking in now
dressed up nice nice jubba nice though
nice beard fixed up doesn't even have to
have a beard anymore
wearing a hat that shoots up this way
and is squared and is big and the hat
alone yeah and you wonder how his neck
can
he can handle the pressure of this pack
right
here and
giving you all these things right these
guys
the guys i'm talking about right
we see this and we say that's a scholar
that's what a scholar looks is that
what a scholar is
said knowledge is light that allah
himself
puts in the heart of the human being
a scholar is someone that it doesn't
matter what he's dressed in
you can see it you can see it in his
eyes
you can see it in the way he deals with
people
you can see it in his humility and when
you ask him a question
the quran in sunnah is on the tip of his
tongue
[Silence]
you ask him a question the first thing
that comes out of his mouth
the quran the sunnah and it's sad to see
because people feel now we need to
reinvent the wheel
you know i need to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's words aren't enough
i need to make up my own words now no
that's not what a scholar does
a scholar shines the light and gets out
of the way
that's what a scholar does now
he he transmits the light of the quran
in sunnah
as unadulterated as possible and he gets
out of the way
a good scholar will make you forget
about himself
and focus on allah and his messenger
sallallahu
just a good reciter of the quran
what is a good reciter of the quran the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
asked this question
[Silence]
who is the best reciter of the quran the
companions asked
the best way to recite the quran he said
the ones whom when you hear them recite
it
you feel their heart
and you feel that they are they
are focused and their heart is in their
recitation
whatever it sounds so a good
reciter of the quran do you want to know
a good reciter of the quran
is one whom when you're listening to him
recite the quran you forget about him
do you know what i'm talking about there
are reciters now that when you listen to
him
you and it's a bit it's like
an opera
right and you're not even listening to
the quran anymore now you're just
thinking about man this man is so gifted
his voice is so beautiful that is not a
good reciter of the quran
a good reciter of the quran is someone
whom
when you listen to him recite the quran
you forget he's even there
he has connected the words of allah to
your heart directly
and he's gotten out of the way that is a
reciter of the quran
that's a true reciter of the quran
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us
that near the end of days near the time
of
the gel he said
speakers will be many
and people of understanding will be few
that's what he said he said the amount
of
people that will be speaking on behalf
of islam
will be very numerous and the amount of
people who understand islam
will be very few during those final days
this is something that's it it is scary
right and i can give you examples of
some of the scholars of islam
and now was
very very known for his harsh stances
against the oppression of the public
by those who are in command
and one time there was a fetwa going
around that the emea had sent
out to the different scholars to sign so
that he could put a man to death
and it was and it was received by imam
and noah he was expected to
sign this this this fatwa
and when imam and noah we read it he
said i'm not signing this
they said why he said in the moon
this is clear oppression i'm not going
to sign this
and so when the emir heard of this
he summoned and now we bring him to me
and now where we came his clothes were
in tatters
and he used to wear a little turban
that was so small it almost didn't cover
his head
and he was very skinny and small that
was his body type because he usually
only ate once a day
and so when noah we came he asked him
why didn't you sign it
he said i will not sign this because
this
is clear oppression and is haram
and so the amir said okay and let him go
his gestures his court ears
the amir they were shocked
because usually somebody this who
would stand in the face of the emir and
say things this
he'd be put in jail or even worse he
said why did you let him go
he said
he said i don't know why but i'm afraid
of that man
now he said i don't know why but i'm
afraid of that man
and it wasn't because his hat was this
big
and it wasn't because he was wearing two
thousand dollars worth of clothes
but because he was a scholar and allah
put fear
in the hearts of those who oppose him
we all know the story of a tether
a tattoo of the mongols mongrels
and how they did to the muslims well
genghis khan his grandson
became muslim
but his islam was not very good
he was still very oppressive
and even
was summoned to come and see him
even tamiya walked in and this is the
mongrels
[Silence]
foreign
the mongrels were absolutely
ruthless and everybody was afraid of
them
and so
even islam was summoned to come and
speak to him and when he came into his
tent
he was invited to drink some tea
or to eat something he said i will not
touch your food
or anything that you have in here
because that would that you are burning
belongs to the muslims
and he continued to point his finger at
him
and walk close to him to the to the
leader of the
mongrels and and
and and
he continued to scold him
on his oppression until his knee was
touching
his knee and his finger was in his chest
telling him you're doing this you're
doing that this is haram this is this
this is that now of course
anyone else would have been put to death
for that that is absolute disrespect
immediately
and so when he left he stood up
and hugged him and escorted him out
the leader of the mongrels
and they asked him why why all this
respect for this man he said
that is a brave man i have respect for
him
these are scholars right
not people that sing to us not people
that have fancy pants
and fancy fancy hats these are not
scholars
and unfortunately it's hard to
distinguish now
and unfortunately i fear
and i do have a lot of hope in the
muslims
and insha allah as promised by the
prophet salallahu
and our honor and nobility will be
restored one day
it will come back but right now
things don't look very good and one of
the reasons for that
is our disrespect for the scholars
you even see that on youtube and
platforms they make little jokes and
memes and they'll have a scholar who's
90 years old
who's memorized sahih al-bukhari and
sahih muslim
who knows the intricacies of the book of
allah and literally
holds the light of revelation in his
heart
they've got some silly meme or if
they've got somebody imitating him
it's some joke and that makes me
scared
because if the jail came out today i
fear
for my muslim brothers and myself that
we would
follow him because we don't ask our
scholars
we don't respect them as they need to be
respected
and respect is not just standing up for
them when they enter into a room
respect is not just walking around and
shaking their hand
and taking pictures with them respect is
that when they speak
you listen and when they say you obey
that is respect why not because this
person is better than me
but because this person holds a position
superior to my position that is why
and so we are done with the issue of
geneza
now next week in sha allah
ibn al-qayyam goes into the issue of
asbab
the reasons and the causes
for your heart to be opened
to the quran in sunnah this is a very
important topic that we will discuss
next week
all of the things if you feel your
heart is hard
and it just doesn't accept the truth
these are the things the steps the
equations that you will take
in order for to open your heart and
crack it open
for the light and the of the quran and
sunnah to shine through
now inshaallah we will hear the ethan
allahuma
[Silence]
me